Bert Kreischer is here Bert wanted to
replace or or put in a new sound bite
for you while you work I have different
ideas well watch y'all pleasure young
fella so stupid it's in perfect it's so
stupid
I want there's got to be an app where
it's a sound bite app where you can just
have those in your life you just have
sound but I get dubsmash was that I like
you know I've seen there's one person I
follow Instagram is that where they
[ __ ] mouth the lyrics to stuff yeah
he's really good at it
yeah it's very valiant aining I bet
you're following her just because you
like dubsmash no I followed her because
I she used to work in a restaurant I
would go into like [ __ ] three times a
week uh-huh
and she lives really guys see there's no
shot but I just enjoy her dubsmash who
is this person some chick who's good at
dubsmash yeah she's like really that's
how I heard of it what's dub smell under
those fish so dubsmash is like they take
things in your lipid I was why would you
in my equation for a bad guy sorry sorry
guy so you gotta get dubsmash is where
they take like like singing along
helping lob it up the softball man we're
not God sorry sir it's when they take
they'll take like five seconds of a song
or like a movie quote or something you
put your own audio and no you don't put
your own audio it's no it's and you it's
like you boys you may get a selfie yeah
so like you're videotaping yourself in a
move your mouth to this stuff no it
doesn't move your mouth with us and then
you play the audio it plays it on your
phone and then you lip-synch it in
Reverse as I say and then you post the
video and then I want I wonder wonder
whatever you want to dubsmash to is that
how it works nice again I wonder wonder
who yeah wrote the book of love right
that's not I'm dumb smash why not nobody
listens to that I don't know I need the
songs on dubs bag I never know how they
rap so fast like what the [ __ ] is it not
really an app though 50s rock and roll
yeah I am I I have an app idea if I'm
afraid of Sega's people would take it
well I know actually I know actually a
guy his name's uh his name's Eddy Cue
and he may be able to help you out with
it if you wanted to share with me my app
it is stupid it's were like you're gonna
put the camera on yourself yeah
and
it's gonna make your hair look blonde
and then it just says blondes have more
fun
that's the whole ads what you did your
app is a snapchat filter it's not that
one they could easily have that one they
definitely don't have more fun to $30 up
telling a ways the way it what are you
gonna sell all the blonde people yeah
what if you're you have blonde hair well
then it's just a confirmation of it
already
no it's a waste of time not a waste of
time are you looking up dubsmash right
now bro geez yeah are you serious yes
are you where the cheese go this can't
be it it's only got 7 stars 7 ratings
and of how many a no that's not it no
dubsmash is a very very popular app is
this it yeah at stab smash I'm getting
it yeah I wanted to do an app called
Bert's bars and I just it was just
Airport bars what time they open I like
how you're making your alcoholism a
cottage industry I'm every time I go to
an airport I'm like like like one
[ __ ] time does this bar open I wish I
tap for that yeah I just tell you all
the airport bars yeah I'm the open I
guess they open it what time do they
like em well new gym in LA tastes open
at six o'clock in the morning 6 a.m. Wow
yes sick Sam's probably the best that we
got around there's other like little
little eccentricities about bars like
you can carry beers around the Chicago
Airport huh which is really nice now
would there be a fun fact section of
Bert's bars so you can find out little
tidbits like that yeah where the Miami
Airport Bert threw up in this bathroom
yeah I did throw up one time in the
bathroom you did yeah I just done Paul
and young Ron and they had bunch of beer
on radio and I had to catch flight and I
got there and I was like still nervous
and I couldn't get a buzz and I was like
it just was like wasn't working by the
way about 40 minutes ago you said you do
not puke when you drink
I know yeah you say that I just
I did beautiful spot now I I just
realized
Jim's Macaulay Culkin from home alone
he's with the robbers coming in within
pauses not young techne whole gay I felt
the animal I'm gonna give you to the
count of ten before I pump your guts
full of lead um but yeah I I was so I
tried to drink vodka sodas but it wasn't
working and so I had a lollipop in my
mouth because I was feeling nauseous
Ollie popping air coach yeah and I went
to the bathroom and I dropped my pants
down and it was in the it was in the
Admirals Club and as soon as I it was a
private bathroom like a like for
families I'm gonna throw up telling the
story and I just uh
soon as I drop my pants on I threw up
over my pants oh but I didn't get any on
me and I was like I was like no harm no
foul how do you how do you say that all
over the floor I stopped drinking on
plain sick for a period of time I try be
let's make you wanna [ __ ] puke in a
bag no no i-i've been drinking on planes
for as long as I've ever flown I have a
rule I do have a genuine fear of flying
but I stopped for a period of time and I
was totally cool and I don't know what
was going on through something about my
diet or what but I was like not getting
panic and I was like I was like holy
[ __ ] this is crazy and I did like maybe
five flights like that what you change
in your diet I have you know valium yeah
no no I'll tell you what I was I was not
drinking the night before the flight oh
and I was taking a xanax the night
before a flight to sleep good and I was
waking up pretty chill so is not the
effects were kind of holding over I
think they were yeah carried over and
then and then I did it one night without
taking his an axe and I owned the plane
I was [ __ ] white-knuckling it I was
like dude I'm telling you I said this is
it's sad to say but like there have been
times where I I'm trying to fly sober
where I just start crying and I'm like
why can't I do this like I'm not even
[ __ ] around sunglasses and I'm like
why the [ __ ] is my brain doing this
where it's literally I go I'm dying
this is I'm dying I'm dying right now
I'm dying this might help they say
you're safer in a plane than you are in
a car every year then
ever hear that no I think Jim has a joke
about this from when from 17 years ago I
probably do yeah a friend of mine but
the car you don't fall 30,000 feet to
your death
yes that's again my dumb old joke I
remember that jokes I was like that is I
think of that joke every time I fly like
yeah that Lesage advice now Jim had like
Jim had like two or three jokes when I
first started that I was like the kind
of like I thought I just come up in your
life where you go like you had this joke
about a sniper and you like what about
his parents anything his parents be
proud of him tonight I don't mind the DC
snipers man no no this but that that
you're like you gotta get this joke
about a sniper and his parents being
proud of him in my mind I'm thinking
military guy who's fighting for his
country and you're like parents being
proud of him was he the DC stick I'm
trying to why would I talk about before
it was before the DC sniper it was about
a race and a guy got to exam to the race
and a sniper shot him and and you were
like
yeah but that in the airplane Joe could
pull up falling 30,000 feet I have no I
don't think about on planes all the
[ __ ] time
yeah have you thought about drinking
less at all it seemed he that work
that's true in general yeah I got yeah
yeah I just I was not drinking for the
last month
Oh God Bert yeah he tried if I want my
prick phones I'll do it myself
but now you're here celebrating yeah and
then I got you know I had [ __ ] kid
things get away from you times see they
do they do you lose track what are you
doing New York right it's called a fun
city yeah who the [ __ ] hey there's no
driving anywhere right English language
this is my house did you that on purpose
yeah he cursed Oh sometimes he hits the
buttons by mistake oh um because I saw a
video of you I just popped up my buddy
Ralph Sutton he posted a video of you
shirtless lifting weights last night
yeah what were you doing [ __ ] gets weird
man yeah I guess so I'm [ __ ] swole ya
know I could tell you look great mom
woke oak is it different
okay so try to sneak in young vernacular
does anyone can apply to the other was
won't woke means like you're like aware
of like like yours right on a different
level of consciousness oh you woke I'm
won't but as swollen woke don't mean
they're do they do no bone I'm woke this
you all they woke in the morning
that's right you're are you I'm yoked
and woke right like yoke this weighs
what you would have been going for that
I'm swollen I'm well he swung slowly
when I woke they're looking very swollen
today yeah we were at the we were
Ralph's than we were lifting weights so
they were doing a podcast and I was like
might as well just bang out some buys
right so we started doing biceps and
then Louis thought he could beat me in a
forearm raised the but he doesn't know
is that so little tidbit when I was not
deserving of headlining what I would
like but I still was headlining and I
was insecure about my act what I would
do is make sure at the end of every show
I take everyone to the bar and we'd
compete in contests and so I'd say is
you wanted to
you mean the audience the audience I
want to beat the audience at contest
that way they knew that it was worth
paying the ticket for know what I wanted
to do is they take them to the bar so
they keep drinking and then sales would
be bigger than anyone elses and so for
the club you're tricking the club
landish the club's objects I take you
know 200 people into the bar and we'd
play games one of the games we do is we
hold beer steins f either like straight
out with your arms straight out or at
your sides in this christ pose and we
see who could do it the most it was a
$20 buy-in we'd have like 40 guys doing
it and the winner got the whole pot I
won every time because all I did was
those [ __ ] exercises I was I was land
sharking them so you were you were good
yeah and so I beat Louis last night you
did of course stay right in that but we
have 30 pound weights and I had for him
and you lose like a workout dramas yeah
those comas Oh in class time is a
workout guy
didn't it was probably stronger than he
looks he's like didn't he I would assume
that he trains like I love fighting
Louis J Gomez I know I know he does but
let's not be on it like he's a specimen
well I'm not saying that mess but it has
a strong message I does exercise here so
I beat him and then I and then what's
crazy is big J
is the one as like the whole things over
big jaysus did it and held it up for 30
seconds and we were like Oh
JJ is a strong guy yeah well yeah you
don't look at him as like a specimen
written that's right how much is the
weight 30 pounds being straight out
straight out for as long as you can I
hold it I think I hold it for like 15
seconds
you could do that not for 30 seconds no
how long our impressive yeah that's
really really great that's really great
how's that I'm very strong going that
way I'm surprisingly fit I guess I could
run a 7-minute mile like that
can you easy is that so is that what you
want to point out when like how is the
battle with you in Tom Segura been
aggressive it has been aggressive right
running in shape and you're trying to
get in better cheated no no no we're
just fat shaming each other you don't
know about the Berta's fat paddle oh I
did hear about that yeah it's been uh
make you fat
thank you lying yeah cuz last I heard
about it was when I spoke to Tom in LA
and that would have been probably August
maybe it was it caught bit caught I mean
Don said him Tom said it got so serious
that he had to call you be like dude
like I hope you're not taking any of
this personally and you were like go
[ __ ] yourself you're not gonna be
sympathetic you're not gonna be nice
okay now he said he goes uh he's like um
I had a me and Doug Benson had like a
weird awkward podcast one time why weird
and awkward it was because I don't know
we manage each other yeah yeah it was it
was it was live and a lot of people saw
it and Doug and I had to like apologize
and figure each other out it was fine
wait wait wait what started it though I
brought out a hundred burgers I bought
100 burgers okay as a gift for the movie
podcast yeah yeah it's like I know yeah
and well I just brought him out he told
me not to and I just I did I did I don't
not to because he didn't want he didn't
want him out there and so I was just
like he figured near it so like Doug on
his movie podcast they throw Donuts
yes yeah so I would imagine that he
probably thought it would be total chaos
and he lose control if there were a
hundred burgers yes sure food fight
maybe I think
that and they do serve food there so it
kind of cuts into like a comedy club
does serve foods I mean giving everyone
a burger kind of different that like the
kinda burgers right there make a from
Burger King you went to Burger King in
just bought a hundred burgers about a
hundred burgers I landed on the plane I
was a little buzzed I went straight to
burger first I called five guys and they
said you should call burger and so I
went to Burger King about a hundred
burgers I then would have to call in
advance is him coming to pick him up
yeah and they go I don't know if we can
do that night go my name is Bert
Kreischer Google me after they googled
me and I go that's me and they're like
the Machine and I go yep I go I'll be
there in ten minutes and then it's like
we'll start making them and so I got
there and they had 100 burgers waiting
for me I brought them in and it was it
did not go well the podcast is you can
get it Doug put a paywall behind a CEO
pay $1 you can listen to it it is
fascinating if you are a fan of comedy
or you fan of dogs or fan of mine it is
[ __ ] are you seen a sniping at each
other the whole time and oh no it's much
worse than that
yeah what happened you walk out with a
hundred burgers in what a bag in a bag
and what'd he say and it killed it
killed and it and put a dog was did not
wanted to have in Doug's listening by
the way Doug Benson listening to yeah
yeah he just texted me so uh I walked up
feel free to call it so huh so I walk in
with the burgers it kills me doing some
bits
I also steamroll it I'm not listening
I'm I'm buzzed so I'm like [ __ ] just
being burped I'm and then Doug at one
point goes fine and walks off stage do
you just do the show Burt and he goes
off stage I think he's joking I go back
to to get him and he's not I realize
he's not joking he's like really upset
and I'm like [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
so why you just talking while he's
trying to get the movie questions out I
was just [ __ ] same role Eddie I would
assume before he walked off his own show
he probably gave you a couple warnings
to please stop talking he did right they
went unheard sheesh I asked many
questions are you doing no it was you I
wouldn't even let him get to the
questions I was just I was I was trying
to be funny
that's definitely like me and Doug did a
podcast about this if you want to hear
that it's on my podcast
it's Doug loves Burt and we talked about
all of this I was trying to be funny
I was trying to kiss of Doug loves
movies the gameplay is not necessarily
my favorite part right I like the chaos
of it I love when DJ Miller's on or
Pete Holmes but little that Doug was
like but I understand that you love that
but it's Doug loves movies so it's not
the first night coming crazy ever he's
looking around
what's the hullabaloo as a sound clip
that was actually Jim saying right so so
then so then I talked to Doug offstage
and I realized he's upset and I go I
should go home and then my brain goes no
you shouldn't you should walk through
this showroom shirtless that'll fix
things and so I did that and Doug really
got upset because you bring the
attention back to your side I know I
know I'm shirtless in the room while
he's trying to do a movie podcast yeah
so you say it like that Jimmy don't you
come in my handy box so here's the
scenario doug is trying to do Doug loves
movies so we start with Bert Kreischer
bringing 100 hamburgers on stage the
Doug is expressly asked him not to do
right
he then steamrolls him and talks
throughout the whole show Doug walks off
Bert realizes Doug is pissed and instead
of just being like okay and cooling out
he takes his shirt off and starts
marching around the room you got go over
I don't go over very well the crowd like
you or no yeah the crowd at the crowd
was the cows mixed is like I think
everyone was like they didn't know it
was a joke they thought it was a bit
they didn't know that Doug was really
upset and then Doug said very plainly if
you want to be a part of the show then
come up here and [ __ ] rebound but I
can't have you do this I want to do this
show and so I went up hat in hand and
tried my hardest to rebound I legit did
you feel like embarrassed
definitely Doug Doug scolded you like
literally like okay all kidding aside if
you don't want to get thrown off the
ship up to the inside of your face get
warm hot shirtless ah she had to walk
back up and put a shirt on so I guess I
would offset their sad nipples his whole
face and chest and belly are all red
good embarrassment oh no and so I tried
my hardest to rebound and then and then
I don't think I don't it did you rebound
do you think I no no you win the game no
no I didn't resign I left the show I
don't remember you left the show I left
the show because it the other it
rebound wasn't gonna happen right it was
it was and I think I'm being fair about
this I had done such damage that the
other guests on the show didn't feel
like they wanted to definitely make sure
that I knew that they didn't like me
okay who else is on Jeff Tate and
another guy on of the other guys Jeff
Tate from screen froze right okay yeah
it's not the same Jeff Tate is you know
it's the there's a comedian tape yeah
and so uh and so it's so I got funny I
got my feelings hurt Jeff Jeff kind of
got into a little bit of a tiff oh no
when I would Jeff say oh I don't know
Jim why are we doing this can I just it
- it's interesting you Jeff was just not
he was not happy he's not happy with me
and he just was uh just look alike yeah
we go condom Jeff is a very sweet guy
various guises but he's he gets mad too
like when he did he came into my show a
while back and he just started going off
on his very liberal
he's very left and so he started talking
about and they also started talking
about Anthony and the fans just [ __ ]
crucified and he's not a person looking
at an Anthony him he's not an Anthony
fan no and I didn't realize that until
we started the conversation I was like
this is anything and he's the kind of
person that would not bite his tongue
right and he didn't and really shouldn't
by this time I mean you should say what
you want to say yeah yeah yeah well I
don't know maybe you know in this forum
you'd be like if you had really not
tackle that subject yet moved do
something else so but anything Anthony
should have been fired
oh yeah a guy I mean I was a whole thing
and and but Twitter if I can destroy him
in Anthony before I on his show and
destroyed him I did oh yeah as a whole
thing he was it was Matt how do i okay
it was it was Matt I don't know how I
met I have missed all this is me Pete
Holmes and TJ Miller uh ed but I love
when a Doug show gets chaotic and so
anyway I dug in and Jeff were kind of
just tagging me they were like making
fun of me and everyone's getting big
laughs and I think my feelings got hurt
and I was once again I was drunk sir and
Jeff got into it
yeah Jeff and I definitely haven't
spoken since really yeah was it was a
real argument would you say back like we
do you think that he was right like you
[ __ ] up no no I I thought I mean I can
say this because uh because it's it I
said it on the posture
but um I thought he was my friend I
thought you'd in that moment of
humiliation that he would help me out of
it but he didn't I don't I think he was
so upset that I was so loud and he
wanted to kind of finish me off mad at
ya and I was and I got my feelings hurt
and I and I said the same to Doug and
then Doug called me the next day and
he's like let's hang out let's figure
this out we did a podcast which is it's
like a two-hour three-hour podcast of me
and Doug in a hotel room
oh boy that must be great we're gonna be
friends again
all right sound great and then we it is
it-it's oh really
cuz it starts off and I go I didn't know
the cheeseburgers that big of a deal and
he's like they [ __ ] they were and it
was like I wish goes it just goes and
and we figured out Doug and I are
totally cool and and I'm I might be I he
was texting about doing another Doug
loves movies possibly and I've done them
but I've done them since and but you and
Jeff Tate are not cool
I haven't talked to him since Wow but
you don't know maybe you are cool you
haven't talked to I don't hate Jeff I've
known Jeff very long a long time yeah
and and my feelings were I didn't want
to talk to him at the time I don't hate
Jeff and I'm you know I don't I don't
want hate you I think I can't help it
man I I get I was I get I cast a large
wake yeah when you make an impact
I positive or negative people love you
people people hate people hate me yeah
oh yeah and there's a lot of people to
hate me yeah are there who else hates
you
we're not getting in this yeah I can't
imagine anybody hating you I love you
rollin loves you I think I just saw him
walking around he loves you a lot of
people that hate me why I don't know man
I cuz I'm loud and I'd [ __ ] don't
realize I do things and like I don't
realize what I'm doing or the impact I'm
having or you correct your behavior do
you be like very self self correcting
you are yeah yeah 100% that's good like
I tried I tried to be but I try to be
sweet nice to everyone sometimes you
know there are people that have their
own issues where they I'm not saying
this is Jeff but they have their own
issues and when they see someone being
loud and having a good time taking his
shirt off and drinking beers all their
[ __ ] comes into them yeah and they're
like then I got how come why is this why
I want to do that or maybe they don't
want to do that I mean they don't like
guys that do that you know oh this the
party's all about this guy can't just
[ __ ] hang out have a normal time why
you gotta stand on the bar right now
right and I'm but I like I like that so
you like to do
say you're loud verbose nature and then
so the other podcast ramen this isn't
actually drama it's just something that
exploded this what we were talking about
a minute ago with listeners to Segura's
podcast is he started saying birds fat
you know he started making jokes bird is
fat and then the audience his his
podcast audience Segura's just started
going nuts well that that's what I was
getting to Doug and I had this incident
yes I called Segura to talk to his guru
about it I was like I got to this bar
after mediate laughter I went to the
hotel bar and I sat down I first thing I
said lady I go I'm gonna talk to you for
two seconds do I sound drunk and she's
like no I'm like perfect one time I said
to somebody I'm not as think as you
drunk I am [ __ ] place went crazy it's
a t-shirt Jim you never said that to
anyone kills no it doesn't didn't even
kill in this room it's [ __ ] hilarious
Bert gave you a laugh that said why
would you interrupt my story for that
because I want to Jacqueline Perrault's
he's mad that I upstage him with that
great joke oh is that worse he doesn't
like it I just cheeseburger him yeah hey
then I cheeseburger them a great job
with a great job I'm not as think as you
drunk I am
think about it no I get on the way home
oh you know what I just got it that I
talked about it drunk and I think it's
it's very very good so I called Tom yeah
and I go hey I need to talk to you and
he just goes I am so sorry and I'm like
not calling about that go about what he
goes you don't know no I don't I go
that's not why I'm calling useful before
you start your thing don't go online I
was like why and he goes Christine and I
were making jokes about you being fat
and it's taken off into like a really
insane place and I go online and I was
like we'll talk about Doug Benson later
what the [ __ ] is this it was like I've
never been I've never had anything go
viral where it's right it's like
thousands of tweets coming in and on my
phones you know I got on my computer you
know what it says like you're on the app
mentions it'll go 77 that replies you're
like whoa what yeah and it just took the
[ __ ] off my agent called me he's like
hey you're trending I was like what he's
like fat shaming
you Amy Schumer and Ke$ha because LOM
Segura was fat shaming Bert Kreischer
and it was I mean it it was they had
like these parody accounts that were
[ __ ] hilarious yeah
and it just was so and then and then he
started feeling really back because once
you get look we can all be a joke about
fat shaming I think if you talk to Amy
about it she's dealt with it here's the
crazy thing
I got thick skin but after I get like a
thousand of these tweets and I am kind
of overweight it's not sitting in your
head you're like [ __ ] man I am a fat and
then you start hearing it it starts
breaking down the wall slowly and slowly
slowly you're like your self-esteem gets
in the [ __ ] and I Segura can see it
he's like dude I'll call him off I go no
you're [ __ ] not going out there like
my mom in her apron like he's got asthma
I was like I'm [ __ ] taking this one
to the chin yeah and I was all your
Chin's Segura ends up going on doing his
his his morning TV shows to promote his
gigs yeah he goes on this is stupid
character DJ dad mouth yeah and he just
had any any gives I don't know how he
[ __ ] does it when I do [ __ ]
morning TV it's some [ __ ] interview
you know I have no control over he goes
in and gives them questions to ask them
would they go like is there anything you
want us to ask about and he goes yes
could you ask me why Bert Kreischer is
so fat and then the woman [ __ ] my name
up she goes she goes well Tom Segura is
here a DJ deadmau5 of a town why is Bert
Chrysler so fat and so everyone started
to call me burnt Chrysler what is DJ dad
know that Tom does have a cigarette a
non-sequitur character that it's it's
only funny in the sense that you go what
the [ __ ] man you're this is it's out of
nowhere it's right I believe Tom Segura
is actually coming in this week so I'll
be able to talk to him about you can't
rely too heavily on a character but
everything look this is DJ dad know and
these guys are like game if I can I
thought I was a cat with that thing real
guy
list oh he does it okay that's time
being
I have it no this is more on my DJing so
the comedies kind of like something on
the side now I just really thought we
don't have any time to watch the whole
thing today but uh it is the one he got
pissed they they got pissed at him for
they did the anchor gets pissed at him
because he's that's his where he said
he's not gender binary anymore the
gender binary right right he's he's
doing away with it yeah
Sonia we made birdies fat Thomas fat
shirts
wait a minute Florida River see I've
done that [ __ ] no show you like it
you a nice I think I did one of the very
first episodes they had Jacksonville my
birthday yeah
so Bert is fat and Thomas fat t-shirts
went on sale and they sold out both of
them uh nope we do until doubt Berta
says he had to reorder like he's like he
was like I'm gonna hold off on the
reorder they're still coming in how is
how is the Thomas fan shirts we are we
often they're available the word in
stock all causes all sides all sizes are
in stock okay no so what if there's like
a big order of them will you be fine
yeah oh yeah you could directly buy 500
of them okay and they'll be here
tomorrow it's a no problem with that but
doc and everyone like I go to clubs I
went to comics at the Mohegan Sun and
everyone had all everyone was wearing
burns fat shirts the whole staff real
nice yeah real nice well listen Bert I'm
glad you stopped by this yeah yeah I've
been excited to see this yeah well if
you're at in LA while we're out there
I'm not there yeah guys what are you
doing it in the mornings we're doing but
we'll do it eight to eleven your time
yeah so it's not five you know it's not
five we'd love to do your podcast I
would love to have you guys what I just
might not serious I just yeah I always
love that please please please
definitely we'll definitely do it
Oh it'll be [ __ ] great good all right
so see you next week I'll see you I've
never done your podcast with Andrew the
house will be done you guys you know why
did your podcast once with Mick Foley
yeah remember me you and Mick game you
and me and you and Roland did one me you
and Rob but that was here in New York
and we had to edit out stuff that now
would be very interesting for listeners
like what well we'll talk to you later
oh yeah I don't even remember what was
said but stuff about the show breaking
up predicting that the show would
probably break up yeah why would that be
edited out that's
right no because I mean at that time as
a little sensitive and I was still the
producer of the show like you know it
was like I was like I don't know is it
open Anthony Odeon Anthony oh yeah I was
like I was like I was like I don't know
man I love like it was I was obviously I
was a huge Opie and Anthony fan yeah I
loved that show man I've still listen to
old replays to this day I listened to
one yesterday somebody sent me a link
and I forgot about it take you forget
bits and it was me and ant talking about
your wedding and um we there's a
hurricane so was like would you cancel
your outdoor wedding for a hurricane and
then I was asking if you would okay but
we the question was what would cause you
to have canceled your wedding and I
asked would you would you cancel the
wedding
if you cost someone less molesting a
child in the bathroom anything I had a
really good time you did dude are you
off to the races I let what I listened
to it twice yesterday I never listened
all the hospital I listened to it twice
because we were joking about course the
specifics about the little suit pants
being pulled down and then uh of course
I said something about because they
would just see the little feet dying it
looked like people would think of
ventriloquist finish it and then Anthony
said how come you dummy all he says ow
dude I [ __ ] screamed listening today
yesterday it's great I lied I listen to
the day that this is a little morbid but
the day
Patrice passed and you guys came on
comedians oh man I was how I was when I
said he died young yet when Bobby's in
the room and everyone's making fun of
that throwing a dinner roll and it all
went David Tao MAME maybe the funniest
joke I've ever heard on the show yeah
where he said come on people I don't
want to try to get donations uh or
something's come on people we got a um
we got a was something about an extra
law a purple suit an extra-large coffee
it was Colin Kent Quinn here's the crazy
part is in the middle of it I jacked off
because I was I was just I was playing
its three-hour thing and I porn came off
and I started watching porn then I was
like I'm gonna jack off but it's the
audio still playing the background of
WikiLeaks has that it's a video of me
sure yeah Jesus
you don't see that porn I got the audio
in the pores it's really gross but yeah
it was that uh it was yeah I still list
of those old shows and toss a man well
you can listen you can watch a new show
on November 11th
go time on Showtime 1111 to 10:00 p.m.
the Machine right 11 limit 10:00 p.m. if
you ever wanted to hear that so means
tell the story about the Russian mafia I
can't imagine that you haven't is uh
it's uh this is the final this is the
quintessential telling is the best
version of that story that I have ever
told and it is done after this I'm done
amazing